jetzt bringt das kochen haben wir uns
aus dem anti viren programm ist
abgelaufen und damit herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen video auf
einem kanal meine lieben freunde ihr
seht schon ich bin auf jeden fall
gewappnet ist dem titel bereits
entnehmen konnte und auch in meiner
kleidung glaube ich schon erkennt geht
es heute augenscheinlich um das corona
wie rolls das irgendwie ja so auftritt
und ihr seht schon hier an dem ihm links
millennial houssine west nile weißes
kleinflugzeug flow and ebola come and go
in time und die medien so kam phau
steckt oder diese kranken maske alter
ich habe mich in den letzten tagen
extrem viel mit dem corona virus
beschäftigt hat mir extrem viele
berichte dazu durchgelesen videos
angeschaut interviews hier eingezogen
und von daher möchte ich euch direkt zu
beginn erst mal erklären was der korona
virus überhaupt ist spoiler der korona
virus hat nichts damit zu tun das ist
das bier namens corona der virus heißt
allerdings vor oder virus weil die viren
unterm mikroskop kronen artig aussehen
und krone auf lateinisch heißt corona
viren sind scheiße wie ihr glaube ich
alle wissen und viren machen in vielen
fällen den körper auch sehr krank und
das einfach aus dem grund weil es die
ausbreitung des virus einfacher macht
also es ist im interesse des virus dass
man krank wird und beispielsweise durch
husten den erreger weiter gibt deswegen
sind wir gerade auch überall auf
instagram und youtube und keine ahnung
wo videos und bilder von leuten die an
sehr gut gefüllten orten wie
beispielsweise flughäfen bahnhöfen mit
solche masken tragen
das liegt einfach daran weil die
infektionsraten erkläre ich euch nachher
im video noch allerdings klären wir
jetzt erstmal die frage woher der korona
virus überhaupt stammt und wie er
übertragen wir haben keine sprünge ist
der korona virus wohl von einem tier auf
einen menschen übertragen worden und das
zu aller wahrscheinlichkeit nach auf
einem sogenannten wochenmarkt mehr oder
weniger inhuman
das ist eine stadt in china und die
verkaufen da unter anderem fische
schlangen fasane und auch fledermäuse
und was ist eine delikatesse in china
frühstück fledermaus suppe und welche
tiere haben die größte vielfalt an
coronaviren dass weder ich will das
video jetzt nicht einblenden weil ich
kein bock auf dass das video hier nicht
mehr freundlich wird weil es wirklich
sehr ekelhaft aussah aber ich glaube
jeder von euch hat dieses video gesehen
was eine chinesin in china natürlich
eine fledermaus suppe gegessen hat das
ist nicht irgendeine suppe mit so ein
bisschen stückchen von der fledermaus
drin oder so sondern das schild halt
eine fledermaus so in der suppe
ja und dann fragt man sich wehren
allerdings wird der virus nicht nur von
fledermaus oder von einem tier oder
keine ahnung was auf den menschen
übertragen sondern auch von mensch zu
mensch
und da gibt es zwei arten der infektion
also wie man sich infizieren kann die
erste art der infektion ist die
sogenannte tröpfcheninfektion und dabei
geht es darum dass wir ein
beispielsweise ihr im flieger sitzt und
die person die gegend gebracht von euch
luca im flieger kann keine person
gegenüber von den sitzen was soll dann
beim stadtfest ihren bräuchte ich dann
durch substanzen rennen oder was anderes
beispiel nehme mal an ihr sitzt im zug
und eine person die gegenüber euch sitzt
trägt den corona virus in sich ist
infiziert und hat schon die ersten
krankheitserscheinungen et cetera pp und
die person nie straight in die fresse
und ihr rad mit dass ein
das ist dann eine tröpfcheninfektion die
zweite art der infektion ist die schwer
infektion und dabei geht es darum wenn
beispielsweise ihr eine kontaminierte
person oder eine oberfläche also eine
kontaminierte oberfläche berührt
beispielsweise also wenn einer oft den
zug tisch dann drauf liest um bei dem
beispiel zu bleiben und ihr berührt
diesen tisch und die reibt euch danach
in die augen oder nase oder mund jannis
quasi eine schmierinfektion und diese
zwei arten also tröpfcheninfektion
schmierinfektion gibt es und es gibt
allgemein zwei riesige problematiken
beim corona virus und zwar erstens dass
es noch kein richtiges heilmittel gibt
also es gibt kein medikament was
speziell gegen den corona virus ist
sondern zurzeit behandelt man lediglich
symptomatisch allerdings wartet man
quasi einfach nur ist der körper
beziehungsweise das eigene immunsystem
mit dem jeweiligen erreger fertig wird
also ja es gibt noch kein richtiges
heilmittel wo die zweite große
problematik ist dass das virus auch
übertragen werden kann wenn man noch
nicht richtig krank ist
falls er es nicht versteht hier ein
kurzes beispiel was sich wirklich so
zugetragen hat weil dadurch ja ist die
erste person in deutschland mit dem
corona virus infiziert worden und zwar
seine frau aus china nach deutschland zu
einer fortbildung geflogen von irgendwem
autovermietungsunternehmen starnberg in
bayern oder so und die frau hatte auf
jeden fall sich den virus in china
geholt hat die mit nach deutschland
gebracht war dort oft der fortbildung
ist dann zurückgeflogen nach hier und
hat erst auf dem rückflug bemerkt ja ich
kann nicht mehr richtig atmen ich glaube
ich hab den corona virus wurde ähnlich
wie dann positiv getestet da hat
allerdings als sie noch nicht gemerkt
hat dass sie krank ist in deutschland
einen deutschen mitarbeiter angesteckt
von dem unternehmen und der bemerkte
dann einige tage später habe dass er
auch krank wurde und dann wurde er auch
positiv auf den corona virus getestet
also man kann auch leute schon anstecken
obwohl man selber nicht mal wirklich
merkt dass man krank ist versteht was
ich meine das ist halt einfach diese
extrem lange inkubationszeit zudem gab
die whu auch noch bekannt dass ein
infizierter im durchschnitt 1,4 bis 25
andere menschen mit dem virus ansteckt
und logischerweise um einen ausbruch zu
stoppen muss diese zahl halt bei unter 1
liegen da viel erfolg kommen nun
allerdings zur dritten frage die ich nun
beantworten möchte und zwar wie
bedrohlich ist das corona virus für
infizierte eigentlich also erstmal gibt
es außerhalb von der volksrepublik china
oder wie die ganzen leute ja gerade in
den videos sagen china keine ahnung wer
die fahrer statt außerhalb von china
gibt es etwas mehr als 80 wirklich
nachgewiesene infektionen also wirklich
sehr sehr sehr sehr wenig in china gibt
es allerdings mehr als 6000 patienten
und zudem weltweit noch 10.000
verdachtsfälle allerdings gibt es auch
insgesamt schon 130 tote und man denkt
jetzt vielleicht hält 130 tote klar sind
wir glaube ich alle einig sind 130 zu
vielen allerdings handelte es sich bei
fast allen todesfällen um sehr alte
menschen die ein extrem schwaches
immunsystem hatten die teilweise schon
schwerwiegende vorerkrankungen hatten
die krebserkrankungen hatten die
herzerkrankungen hatten etc das waren
jetzt nicht quicklebendige 18 jährige
sportler oder so und außerhalb von china
gibt es übrigens auch noch gar keinen
todesfall also dass auch mal nur ganz
kurz nur in form und ich meine wie
vorhin schon gesagt 130 totes und 130 zu
viel ich darf das sind wir alle der
gleichen meinungen allerdings habe ich
für euch jetzt nochmal zwei zahlen
vergleichsweise zur grippe und zwar gibt
es bei der grippe drei bis fünf
millionen
schwere fälle weltweit pro jahr und von
diesen drei bis fünf millionen sterben
pro jahr an der grippe 290 bis 650.000
menschen so ein bisschen im vergleich so
corona virus und grippe kommen nun
allerdings auch endlich zu letzten
trockenen frage die ich hier beantworten
möchte und weiß ist ob ich eine frage
die sich jeder irgendwie den letzten
tagen schon mal gestellt hat und zwar
wie könnt ihr euch schützen also klar
ich will jetzt nicht sagen wenn ihr
täglich sport macht oder trinkt ihr
morgens eine heiße zitrone und es gemüse
und trinkt genug wasser dass sie quasi
unsterblich seit allerdings ist es halt
bei neuen erregern immer so dass extrem
viel panik darum und auch kraß hallt von
den medien extrem für panik geschaffen
wird allerdings teile ich da unter
anderem auch die meinung von hans georg
häuslicher ist virologe in heidelberg
und jens spahn dass unser
bundesgesundheitsminister und zwar sehe
ich es auch so dass hier überhaupt
keinen grund zur besorgnis besteht also
ich habe hier auch letztes und video
zugeschickt bekommen bei whatsapp die
medien wollen davon das verschweigen
leitet dieses video weiterhin wie zehn
minuten lang wurde der effekt drop wie
tackelt das alles ist also wenn man sich
ein bisschen informiert und nicht nur
solchen videos dann glaubt dann sind
glaube ich alle einer meinung wenn man
da so ein bisschen auf expertenmeinungen
ja sich darauf verlässt und auf ärzte
aussagen und leute die das wirklich
studiert haben über jahre hinweg die
wissen auch dass es immer solche viren
gibt es gab in es geht gibt jedes jahr
irgendwie neuen virus oder viel öfter
sogar und klar ich will das jetzt nicht
kleinreden so es sind menschen an dem
virus gestorben allerdings ich glaube
man kann sich ganz gut davor schützen
und zwar sollte man wirklich einfach
immer auf seine hygiene achten also
händewaschen desinfektionsmittel
rumtragen klar wenn ihr extrem paris hat
könnt ihr auf eine maske aufsetzen
also wenn euch da leute an ließen dann
seid ihr auf jeden fall safe und klar
ihr solltet jetzt natürlich auch nicht
nach china reisen und plötzlich
fledermäuse essen und fasane und keine
ahnung was aber ich glaube dann hat man
noch ganz andere probleme ich will ja
aber auch nicht die ganze zeit ist zu
trocken bei den virus reden ich wollte
nur ein bisschen
weil das sich alle ein bisschen
runterschrauben m ich habe ich auch ganz
viele artikel dazu unten in der
beschreibung verlinkt ich möchte jetzt
auch wirklich wie auch schon mehrmals
gesagt gar nicht die person sein die
sagt von easy peasy so der virus wie
gesagt es sind menschen daran gestorben
allerdings ist ja im vergleich zur
grippe so überlegt einfach mal und auch
die leute die gestorben sind eh schon
personen die in extrem schwaches
immunsystem haben und ältere leute sind
da anfällig für und ja wir schauen uns
jetzt noch ein paar - dazu an
denn das internet hat natürlich auch
wieder egal wie ernst das thema jetzt
werden es schon beim dritten weltkrieg
der dann wirklich nicht ausgebauten ist
obwohl alle sich auch wieder zum
vermeintlichen dritten weltkrieg gab es
auf jeden fall auch schon extrem leiste
- oder zum corona virus habe ich einige
rausgesucht ich würde sagen wir fangen
gleich an mit diesem hier die korona wie
russland lässt long kosmos made in
trendige klamotten im jahr 2019 und
trendige klamotten im jahr 2020 und das
bieten was du c am meisten gespendet
wurde war das hier ja krone hat übrigens
schon gesagt sie wollen lieber wenn er
hier ist haben wir uns nicht in china
doppelpunkt wir arbeiten mit hochdruck
an einer lösung deutschland doppelpunkt
wir verteilt diese burschen corona virus
doppelpunkt miriel ein schönes made in
china hat auf jeden fall komplett
richtig gemacht und sie ja hat er hat
auch hat auch alles richtig gemacht
wer dann blöd wenn du wirklich wenn du
wirklich im 40er snow an
[Musik]
ja was ist auch richtig so
also wenn man gerade in china ist also
ich hab ich ja gesagt über 6000 leute
sind schon infiziert in china aber 380
sonst wo auf der ganzen welt also wenn
ich wirklich in china gerade wäre würde
ich wahrscheinlich auch so unserer
babbel rumlaufen aber wir gerade in
deutschland macht euch nicht so viel
gedanken lebt euer leben achtet auf eure
hygiene hygiene und das euro an der
stelle ich das heutige jetzt allerdings
auch beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
ich euch ein bisschen aufklären konnte
war den kohona virus die hintergründe
und euch vielleicht ein bisschen
lustigen konnte mit den minis und
eventuell auch den ein oder anderen tipp
näher bringen konnte wie ihr euch ja
generell vor dem corona virus oder
anderen währung schützen könnt dann das
gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem video
hier da abonniert main kanal falls noch
keine luxus schickt dieses video hier
gerne euren freunden die euch panikmache
bezüglich des corona virus also wie
gesagt es ist bei jedem neuen erreger so
dass da erstmal panik gemacht wird das
war schon immer so das wird auch immer
so sein weil es einfach fast neues ist
allerdings ist die medizin ausgefeilt
hat in jena ich sehe das genauso wie der
bundesgesundheitsminister und auch die
world health organisation und alle
anderen sehe ich da keine riesige
bedrohung als wenn jetzt milliarden
menschen sterben werden
aber naja ist ansichtssache da
vielleicht noch morgen alle tot
[Musik]